Katrina:  然后我们有那种大音箱不
Katrina: So do we have those big speakers?
Shure:  这个可以有
Shure: We can get those.
Katrina:  如果在外面玩的话放点音乐啥
Katrina: If we play outside, we can put on some music.
Jake: 嗯就放刚刚那个曲子
Jake: Yeah, let's play that song from earlier.
Lucia: 嗯对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Alice: 大东 北
Alice: Northeast China
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Shure: 大东北
Shure: Northeast China.
Katrina: 知识问答自我介绍
Katrina: Trivia and self-introductions.
Jake:拿走把这个
Jake: Take this away.
Jake: 花瓶
Jake: The vase.
Katrina:  这是真的酒还是假酒
Katrina: Is this real liquor or fake?
Jake: 假酒
Jake: Fake.
Katrina: 啊我还以为你们已经喝了
Katrina: Ah, I thought you guys had already drunk it.
Jake: 这是我的水瓶
Jake: This is my water bottle.
Jake:茅台茅台
Jake: Maotai, Maotai.
Katrina:  再拿起出来干一口
Katrina: Take another swig.
Jake: 那花瓶拿走了还倒
Jake: The vase is gone, but you still pour.
Katrina:  这多的话等会就放
Katrina: There's a lot, we'll put it later.
Katrina:  这花瓶
Katrina: This vase.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over.
Alice: 叮铃咣当的
Alice: Clink-clank.
Shure:  这是个保温杯啊
Shure: This is a thermos.
Lucia: 这居然是保温杯
Lucia: This is actually a thermos.
Shure:  一听就是304不锈钢
Shure: You can tell it's 304 stainless steel.
Lucia: 厉害了
Lucia: Impressive.
Jake: 很懂啊大东北
Jake: You really know your stuff about Northeast China.
Jake: 生产的是吧
Jake: Manufactured there, right?
Jake: 东北钢铁厂
Jake: Northeast Steel Plant.
Shure:  鞍钢
Shure: Anshan Steel.
Shure:  这字写的太好看了
Shure: The writing is so beautiful.
Shure:  真的嗯
Shure: Really, yeah.
Jake:嗯 一看就是中文
Jake: Yeah, you can tell it's Chinese.
Shure:  可歌可泣
Shure: Epic.
Shure:  哦我们还要写个英文版吗
Shure: Oh, do we also need to write an English version?
Jake: 不用不用不用
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 对说明我们字写的好
Jake: It just shows our writing is good.
Shure:  我们应该international一点
Shure: We should be more international.
Shure:  你看我那个英文就明显跟这个
Shure: Look, my English is obviously different from this.
Jake: 那好下面开始写英文吧
Jake: Alright, let's start writing in English then.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Jake: 时间线来
Jake: Timeline, please.
Shure:  来来咱俩换一下
Shure: Come on, let's switch places.
Shure:  你去那边坐一会去
Shure: You go sit over there for a bit.
Jake: 或坐这
Jake: Or sit here.
Shure:  timeline
Shure: Timeline.
Jake: 为啥是俩词
Jake: Why is it two words?
Alice: 时间线吧
Alice: Timeline, right?
Jake: 为啥是俩词
Jake: Why is it two words?
Jake: 也行也行
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure:  强调一下这个line好好线
Shure: Emphasize this line... okay, line.
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Shure:  首先我们几点入场
Shure: First, what time do we arrive?
Jake: 3点 3点吧
Jake: 3 o'clock, 3 o'clock.
Jake: 应该是2点到3点逐步入场
Jake: It should be from 2 to 3, gradually arriving.
Jake: 然后前面可能签到的人
Jake: And then maybe the early arrivals will sign in.
Katrina: 逛逛
Katrina: Walk around.
Jake: 对给他们一点活动
Jake: Yeah, give them some activities.
Shure:  鹌鹑哈哈
Shure: Quail, haha.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  入场是怎么拍的吗
Shure: How are the arrivals being recorded?
Katrina:  2点半到3点
Katrina: 2:30 to 3:00.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake:对 这意思就是3点之前
Jake: Yes, that means before 3 o'clock.
Jake: 我们搞一些flexible的游戏或者活动
Jake: We'll have some flexible games or activities.
Jake: 然后3点准时干点什么东西
Jake: And then at 3 o'clock, we'll do something.
Shure:  game
Shure: Game.
Shure:  before
Shure: Before.
Shure:  是不是污染数据
Shure: Does it contaminate the data?
Jake: 不污染
Jake: No, it doesn't.
Jake: 这是人类的正常行为
Jake: It's normal human behavior.
Shure: 第二点
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else?
Jake:然后 3点干啥了
Jake: And then, what do we do at 3 o'clock?
Katrina:  3点开始就有知识问答和自我介绍
Katrina: At 3 o'clock, we'll have a Q&A and introductions.
Shure:  那这这些呢
Shure: And these?
Katrina:  这些就是我们要让他们先获得货币
Katrina: These are for us to let them earn currency first.
Katrina:  以后我们再推销我们自己的产品
Katrina: Then we can promote our own products.
Katrina:  我其实感觉不确定
Katrina: I'm actually not sure about it.
Katrina:  他们到底是一人还是二人
Katrina: Are they one person or two?
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: Do you know?
Katrina:  就万一
Katrina: Just in case...
Katrina:  其实可能不会持续很长的时间
Katrina: It might not last very long.
Katrina:  自我介绍
Katrina: Self-introduction.
Katrina:  知识问答40分钟吧
Katrina: Knowledge quiz for 40 minutes, maybe.
Katrina:  加自我介绍
Katrina: Plus self-introduction.
Shure:  您说也行
Shure: Sure, if you say so.
Jake: 也行抢答对吧
Jake: Sure, we can do a quick-answer format, right?
Katrina:  嗯很快其实
Katrina: Yeah, it will be quick actually.
Jake: 对对挺好
Jake: Yes, that sounds good.
Shure:  知识问答昂
Shure: Knowledge quiz.
Katrina: QA
Katrina: QA.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  第3点
Shure: Point three.
Katrina:  然后就每个人介绍自己做的这个
Katrina: Then everyone introduces what they are doing.
Katrina:  然后就跟他们说
Katrina: Then tell them.
Katrina:  他们可以拿他们的货币来
Katrina: They can use their currency to...
Jake: 大家插会电吧
Jake: Everyone plug in.
Jake: 来你们继续聊
Jake: Continue chatting.
Jake: 我给大家发线
Jake: I will distribute the wires.
Katrina:  40
Katrina: Forty.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then?
Jake: 哦你一直插着的
Jake: Oh, you always keep it plugged in.
Jake:充电宝 牛啊
Jake: Power bank, nice.
Shure:  我一直插着充电宝
Shure: I always keep it plugged in.
Jake: 这个是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Katrina:  我我的
Katrina: Mine.
Jake: 好那你插上吧少一个
Jake: Alright, plug it in, one less.
Shure:  3
Shure: Three.
Katrina: 介绍自己的产品吗
Katrina: Introduce our products?
Katrina:  每个人啊
Katrina: Each person?
Shure:  3就开始拍卖
Shure: Three, and then start the auction.
Shure:  怎么说
Shure: How about that?
Shure:  啊IUCA
Shure: Ah, IUCA.
Jake: 也插一个吧
Jake: Plug in one more.
Lucia: OK谢谢
Lucia: OK, thank you.
Shure:  预计3:40到
Shure: Expected to arrive at 3:40.
Lucia: 一个小时或许
Lucia: About an hour, maybe.
Shure:  4点半吧差不多
Shure: Around 4:30, I guess.
Lucia: 和咱们的产品
Lucia: And our product...
Lucia: 不止吗那就再长一个半小时
Lucia: Not enough? Then let's extend it by another hour and a half.
Katrina:  一个半小时差不多
Katrina: An hour and a half should be enough.
Shure:  主要是我们可以细分
Shure: Mainly, we can break it down.
Shure:  这个是他们自己的部分
Shure: This is their own part.
Shure:  这是guest part
Shure: This is the guest part.
Lucia: 这些这些
Lucia: These, these...
Jake:啊你不用
Jake: Ah, you don't need...
Lucia: 这些gets
Lucia: These gets...
Lucia: 他们带多少东西
Lucia: How much stuff are they bringing?
Lucia: 以及他们是矮人还是艺人
Lucia: And are they dwarves or artisans?
Lucia: 对这就不确定
Lucia: Yeah, that's uncertain.
Shure:  然后还有什么我们的
Shure: And what else is ours?
Shure:  或者我们可以提前来
Shure: Or we could come early.
Shure:  活跃一下这个气氛
Shure: To liven up the atmosphere.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  我觉得我们先开始吧
Katrina: I think we should start first.
Katrina:  我们先开始
Katrina: Let's start first.
Katrina:  3:40到4点半
Katrina: From 3:40 to 4:30.
Katrina:  是我们先开始
Katrina: We'll start first.
Shure:  我们会会这么长
Katrina: 每个人7  8分钟差不多
Katrina:  七八分钟
Katrina: Seven or eight minutes.
Katrina:  那40分钟差不多
Katrina: So, 40 minutes should be enough.
Katrina:  那就4:20
Katrina: So, at 4:20.
Lucia: 或者
Lucia: Or...
Lucia: 直接把他们把这段变成我们整体的
Lucia: We could turn this segment into part of our overall plan.
Lucia: 一个
Lucia: Like...
Lucia: 怎么形容一个小续集也行
Lucia: How to describe it, a mini sequel could work.
Lucia: 就是可以让他们先对
Lucia: Like, let them first...
Lucia: 就是如果对咱们整体的这个手工制品
Lucia: If they're interested in our handmade crafts.
Lucia: 感觉就好比我们是一个商家一样
Lucia: It feels like we're a merchant.
Lucia: 嗯只不过使用的是这个虚拟货币
Lucia: Except we're using this virtual currency.
Lucia: 对然后如果大家玩的比较高兴的
Lucia: And if everyone has fun,
Lucia: 话就后面让他们在自己之间交换
Lucia: They can trade among themselves afterward.
Katrina:  哦六六个瓶子吗
Katrina: Oh, six bottles?
Katrina:  然后多的就放这种公共的
Katrina: And the extras can be put in the common area.
Katrina:  刚才还有花瓶啥的
Katrina: And there were vases and stuff.
Katrina:  对先醒醒他吧
Katrina: Yeah, let him wake up first.
Jake: 好我们的食品环节吃饭环下午茶环节
Jake: Okay, our food session, the meal and afternoon tea session.
Jake: 在什么地方
Jake: Where is it?
Shure:  啊要有一直有一个酒保在那边
Shure: Ah, there should always be a bartender over there.
Lucia: 哈哈哈一直有一个酒保
Lucia: Hahaha, there's always a bartender.
Jake: 那酒保在什么位置呢
Jake: So, where is the bartender located?
Katrina:  我感觉就外面这里已经很好了
Katrina: I think just outside here is good enough.
Jake: 那调酒是在外面
Jake: So, the mixing is done outside?
Lucia: 但是但是但是我喝酒
Lucia: But but but I drink...
Lucia: 调酒是在这个台子上调
Lucia: The mixing is done on this counter.
Jake:得弄一个台子
Jake: We'll need a counter.
Jake: 也可以啊在室内然后如果有人就进来
Jake: It can be inside, and if someone comes in...
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Lucia: 对刚才那表演就是
Lucia: Yeah, the performance just now...
Lucia: 大家在外面的玻璃就可以看到
Lucia: Everyone outside can see through the glass...
Lucia: 调酒师在里面如何调
Lucia: How the bartender mixes inside.
Katrina: 哇好高级啊
Katrina: Wow, so fancy.
Jake:对对是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Lucia:  来来一点打光
Lucia: Let's get some lighting.
Lucia: 哈哈哈对
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 对我们还有这个影棚灯
Lucia: Yes, we also have this studio light.
Lucia: 虽然这个我们是就一个
Lucia: Although we only have one...
Lucia: 一个灯吗
Lucia: One light?
Jake: 我们有四个
Jake: We have four.
Lucia: 昂OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Jake: 现在还没装晚一会装一下
Jake: They're not set up yet, we'll set them up later.
Katrina:  那那下午茶时间要不要弄到4:20之后
Katrina: So, should we move the afternoon tea to after 4:20?
Katrina:  要不然插在哪个地方
Katrina: Otherwise, where should we fit it in?
Shure:  就大家边吃边干
Shure: We'll just eat and work at the same time.
Lucia: 我觉得四点二十之后也可以
Lucia: I think after 4:20 is fine too.
Lucia: 因为一般来说
Lucia: Because usually...
Lucia: 下午茶就是3点到5点这个时间段
Lucia: Afternoon tea is from 3 to 5 PM.
Jake: 就可能我们一一部分人
Jake: So, maybe some of us...
Jake: 还是我们先做好
Jake: Should we prepare first?
Jake: 我们可以先做好吗
Jake: Can we prepare first?
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 就是那些甜品
Jake: I mean the desserts.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 可以先做好
Jake: We can prepare first.
Katrina:  哎那就是反正他他他是种子片
Katrina: Oh, I mean, he, he, he is the seed...
Katrina:  就加甜品
Katrina: Just add desserts.
Katrina:  就在3:40-4:20介绍
Katrina: Introduce it between 3:40 to 4:20.
Katrina:  然后他作为我们几个的压轴
Katrina: Then he will be our finale.
Katrina:  然后介绍完了以后大家可以分发一下
Katrina: After his introduction, everyone can distribute it.
Jake:买甜品是吧哈哈
Jake: Buy desserts, right? Haha.
Katrina:  尝一下他的那个甜品
Katrina: Try his desserts.
Katrina:  对他们是摆台
Katrina: Yes, they are setting up.
Jake:先发甜品
Jake: Distribute the desserts first.
Katrina:  也有钱了嘛
Katrina: They have money now.
Jake:有三颇
Jake: There are three big pieces.
Tasha: 甜品摆台吗
Tasha: Dessert setup?
Jake: 摆什么
Jake: Setup what?
Tasha: 甜品摆台
Tasha: Dessert setup.
Lucia: 那种三层塔的
Lucia: The three-tier tower kind.
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Ah, ah.
Jake:可以摆啊可以摆摆
Jake: Yes, we can set it up, go ahead.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Jake:当然可以摆啊对
Jake: Of course, we can set it up.
Tasha: 嗯好的
Tasha: Okay, got it.
Tasha: 那就是甜品台做一次要800-1,000呢
Tasha: But setting up a dessert table costs 800-1,000.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  怎么杨老板突然空手了
Shure: Why is Jake suddenly empty-handed?
Jake: 可以可以可以
Jake: It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Tasha: 没有只是买个甜品台架子
Tasha: No, it's just buying a dessert table stand.
Jake: 架子1,000是吧
Jake: The stand is 1,000, right?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Jake: 那是什么
Jake: Then what?
Alice: 总共的吧
Alice: The total, I guess.
Jake: 总共500-1,000
Jake: The total is 500-1,000.
Tasha: 你去做的话
Tasha: If you do it yourself.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  哎但是你需不需要很多机器啊
Katrina: But don't you need a lot of machines?
Tasha: 嗯基础的买了
Tasha: Hmm, bought the basic ones.
Tasha: 嗯除湿机什么的肯定没买
Tasha: But definitely didn't buy a dehumidifier or anything like that.
Jake: 能能多少钱
Jake: How much could it cost?
Tasha: 嗯不能买
Tasha: Hmm, can't buy it.
Jake: 呵呵呵不能买是什么
Jake: Hehe, why can't you buy it?
Jake: 太贵了
Jake: Too expensive.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:  上万
Jake: Over ten thousand.
Tasha: 嗯几千块钱吧
Tasha: Hmm, a few thousand yuan maybe.
Jake: OK确实
Jake: OK, sure.
Tasha: 甜品台就类似这样子
Tasha: The dessert table would look something like this.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Katrina:  啊看一眼好漂亮啊
Katrina: Ah, look at it, it's so pretty.
Katrina:  对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 差不多是我设想的那个大盘子好漂亮
Lucia: It's almost like the big plate I imagined, so pretty.
Tasha: 到时候坐在这里
Tasha: You can sit here later.
Tasha: 可以就想去吃
Tasha: And just want to eat it.
Lucia: 我每次开学术会议的时候去学校就疯狂携带
Lucia: Every time I go to an academic conference at school, I just grab as much as I can.
Jake:对对对就是为了这个哈哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's the whole point, haha.
Tasha: 就是哈哈哈
Tasha: Exactly, haha.
Katrina:  学术蝗虫
Katrina: Academic locusts.
Tasha: 是这样的
Tasha: That's how it is.
Jake:可以
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这样子的
Tasha: Haha, exactly.
Lucia: 而且关键是老师一般都不怎么吃
Lucia: And the key thing is, the teachers usually don't eat much.
Lucia: 结果都是我吃
Lucia: So I end up eating it all.
Jake: 还打包打了一包回去
Jake: I even packed some to take home.
Jake: 烧烤吗
Jake: BBQ?
Katrina:  烧烤偏晚上吧
Katrina: BBQ is more of an evening thing.
Jake: 晚上再烧
Jake: Grill in the evening.
Katrina:  那就是但是你要留他们到晚上的话
Katrina: But if you want to keep them until the evening...
Katrina:  这个晚饭怎么弄
Katrina: How about dinner?
Shure:  大家一起烤呗
Shure: Everyone grills together.
Jake:就是烤呗
Jake: Yeah, just grill together.
Shure:  一起吃烧烤
Shure: Eat BBQ together.
Shure:  一起吃这个是吗
Shure: Eat this together, right?
Jake: 一起吃什么
Jake: Eat what together?
Katrina:  烧烤的人有点累哦因为有20个人左右
Katrina: BBQing for so many people is tiring, there are about 20 people.
Lucia: 如果来的人多的话
Lucia: If a lot of people come...
Jake:烧烤太多了
Jake: BBQ is too much.
Lucia: 就是都烧烤还挺麻麻烦的
Lucia: BBQ for everyone is pretty troublesome.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 而且包饭也麻烦你 点外卖也麻烦
Katrina: And making packed meals is troublesome, ordering takeout is troublesome.
Katrina:  放进去啊
Katrina: Just put it in.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: True.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina: 哎点披萨倒还行
Katrina: Hey, ordering pizza might work.
Lucia:哎 对就是可能每人吃那么一两块
Lucia: Yeah, everyone could just have a slice or two.
Lucia: 也不是说要吃的非常饱嘛
Lucia: Not like everyone needs to be super full.
Shure:  蘸点披萨
Shure: Dip some pizza
Shure:  有那个32寸这么大
Shure: It's as big as 32 inches
Jake: 好行
Jake: Okay, sure
Shure:  行可以弄一张就可以
Shure: Yeah, one will be enough
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake:那就管晚饭吧 对对
Jake: Then let's have it for dinner, yeah
Katrina:  就到了晚饭的点就摆在这
Katrina: Just put it here when it's dinner time
Katrina:  对大家饿了自己拿点吃
Katrina: Everyone can grab some when they're hungry
Jake:五点吃ok
Jake: Okay, let's eat at 5
Lucia: 而且如果之前
Lucia: And if earlier
Lucia: 有
Lucia: If
Lucia: 吃甜的东西的话可能也不会特别的饿
Lucia: We had some sweets, we might not be that hungry
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake: 那就5点半的时候
Jake: So at 5:30
Jake: 一个大披萨
Jake: A big pizza
Jake:差不多
Jake: Almost
Katrina:  嗯现在是5点
Katrina: Hmm, it's 5 now
Katrina:  嗯 5点
Katrina: Yeah, 5
Katrina:  那我们的节目就弄到晚上一样
Katrina: Then our program will go on into the evening
Katrina:  因为我当时想的是
Katrina: Because I was thinking
Katrina:  你那个讲故事的话大家不是很熟
Katrina: If you tell stories, people aren't very familiar
Katrina:  因为你那个讲故事设定在酒吧
Katrina: Because your story setting is in a bar
Katrina:  根据酒吧大家都是有故事的人
Katrina: In a bar, everyone has stories to tell
Katrina:  可能就在那种环境下
Katrina: Maybe in that environment
Katrina:  然后就愿意讲
Katrina: They'd be willing to share
Katrina:  但是我们这种刚过来
Katrina: But since we just arrived
Katrina:  他们可能不太愿意讲故事
Katrina: They might not want to share stories
Katrina:  所以改成自我介绍还挺好
Katrina: So changing to self-introductions is good
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then
Katrina:  如果说要讲故事或获金币这个环节
Katrina: If we have a story-telling or coin-winning segment
Katrina:  我觉得可以弄到偏晚上一点
Katrina: I think we can do it later in the evening
Katrina:  大家已经熟了一点
Katrina: When people are more familiar
Katrina:  再加上晚上比较感性
Katrina: Plus, people are more emotional at night
Katrina:  可以带着一点自己的故事过来
Katrina: They can bring their own stories
Katrina:  然后那
Katrina: And then
Katrina:  那就5点
Katrina: So at 5
Katrina:  是他们介绍完他们的pass
Katrina: After they finish their introductions
Katrina:  然后5点到6点就吃烧烤调酒这种吗
Katrina: Then from 5 to 6 we can have BBQ and drinks
Jake:可以啊来
Jake: Sure, let's do that
Katrina:  其实他并不会完全严格的按照这个
Katrina: Actually, it won't be strictly according to this
Jake:上字
Jake: Next word.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  对所以可以搞个5点到6点的区间
Katrina: Yeah, so we can aim for a 5 to 6 PM window.
Shure:  反正开饭dinner
Shure: Anyway, let's have dinner.
Shure:  在5点半之后
Shure: After 5:30 PM.
Shure:  5点半左右嗯
Shure: Around 5:30, yeah.
Jake: 大披萨
Jake: Big pizza.
Jake: a bow
Jake: A bow.
Jake: 第一个披萨可以
Jake: The first pizza is fine.
Shure:  bbq
Shure: BBQ.
Katrina:  那调酒的话是属于贯穿始终
Katrina: So the cocktails will be throughout the event.
Shure:  对就像甜品和
Shure: Yeah, just like desserts and...
Shure:  甜品就是
Shure: Desserts are...
Katrina:  他们入场的时候
Katrina: When they enter.
Shure:  嗯还是SS
Shure: Yeah, still SS.
Jake:SS乘2
Jake: SS times 2.
Katrina:  哦你说甜品啊
Katrina: Oh, you mean desserts?
Shure:  and
Shure: And...
Katrina:  那晚上就还剩啥
Katrina: So what's left for the evening?
Katrina:  我想想还剩我们的节目
Katrina: Let me think, our show is left.
Jake: 对我们有
Jake: Yeah, we have...
Katrina:  然后也不能弄太晚
Katrina: And we can't make it too late.
Katrina:  他们回去的话要两个小时
Katrina: It takes them two hours to get back.
Jake: 嗯那我们就定个结束时间
Jake: Yeah, so we'll set an end time.
Katrina: 八点
Katrina: 8 PM.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  2点半到8点差不多了
Katrina: 2:30 PM to 8 PM is about right.
Katrina:  忙够呛了
Katrina: Busy enough.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  跟戴娜差不多
Katrina: Similar to Dana.
Katrina:  到6点半
Katrina: Until 6:30 PM.
Katrina:  然后还有一个半小时就是表演
Katrina: Then there's an hour and a half for performances.
Katrina:  表演节目
Katrina: Performances.
Katrina:  能让他们也准备点节目吗
Katrina: Can we also ask them to prepare something?
Katrina:  有没有那种擅长唱歌的
Katrina: Anyone good at singing?
Shure:  可以反正我们有把吉他
Shure: Sure, we have the guitar anyway.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  啊唱唱歌跳跳舞
Katrina: Ah, singing and dancing.
Jake: 对时间太长了中间得
Jake: Yeah, it's a long time, we need...
Lucia: 来一个大家一起卡拉OK的环节吧
Lucia: Let's have a karaoke session for everyone.
Jake:昂也可以
Jake: Hmm, that works too.
Katrina:  哪个时间太长
Katrina: That time is too long.
Jake: 不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我我我是说中间可能有一个小时
Jake: What I'm saying is there might be an hour in between.
Jake: 我们要传数据
Jake: We need to transfer data.
Jake: 你们的眼镜
Jake: Your glasses.
Katrina:  传数据让他们自己逛逛我们的世界
Katrina: Transfer data and let them wander around our world.
Katrina:  然后喝点酒
Katrina: And then have some drinks.
Lucia: 传数据的时候带大家唱唱歌好了
Lucia: We can sing some songs while transferring data.
Tasha: free time在这放一个小电影或者干嘛的
Tasha: During free time, we can play a short film or something.
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure, sure.
Shure:  小电影
Shure: A short film.
Lucia: 小电影可以
Lucia: A short film works.
Jake: 对中间中间空一个小时出来
Jake: Yes, let's leave an hour in between.
Shure:  对啊对当时还说那个什么什么记录片什么的
Shure: Yeah, remember we talked about some documentary or something.
Katrina: 大概是几点到几点
Katrina: What time is that roughly?
Jake:额就三点到六五点半吧五点半
Jake: Umm, around 3 to 5:30, 5:30.
Katrina:  那就是那个5点结束之后呗
Katrina: So, after it ends at 5?
Jake: 对啊他家吃披萨时候咱就不拍了吧
Jake: Yeah, we won't shoot while they're having pizza, right?
Jake: 行吧
Jake: Okay?
Tasha: 甜品是什么时候哪个时间段吃
Tasha: When are we having dessert, at what time?
Jake:甜品什么时候
Jake: When's dessert?
Katrina:  甜品是你就是我
Katrina: Dessert, you're the host.
Katrina:  host host part就是他们一二环节
Katrina: Host part is in the first two segments.
Katrina:  不是会得金币吗
Katrina: You can earn coins, right?
Katrina:  然后3:40到4:20的时候
Katrina: And then from 3:40 to 4:20.
Katrina:  我们介绍我们的产品
Katrina: We introduce our products.
Katrina:  然后我想的是你放在最后
Katrina: I was thinking you go last.
Katrina:  然后就是刚好这个part结束了
Katrina: So when this part ends,
Katrina:  以后大家就可以尝你的甜品
Katrina: Everyone can try your dessert.
Tasha: 4:20 对
Tasha: 4:20, right.
Katrina:  就是你压轴
Katrina: You're the finale.
Katrina:  哈哈你介绍你的种子片和你的甜品
Katrina: Haha, you introduce your seed cookies and your dessert.
Katrina:  我们介绍我们自己做的那种
Katrina: We'll introduce what we made ourselves.
Jake: 嗯3点到5点两个小时够挺好
Jake: Hmm, 3 to 5, two hours should be good.
Tasha: 大概从早上就要开始准备
Tasha: We'll probably need to start preparing in the morning.
Tasha: 然后需要配两个人
Tasha: And we'll need two people.
Katrina:  可以我可以帮忙
Katrina: I can help.
Katrina: 就想写
Katrina: Just want to write it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈配两个人
Tasha: Hahaha, need two people.
Shure: 真的起的来吗
Shure: Can you really wake up?
Katrina:  可以的我今天只是失误
Katrina: Yes, I just made a mistake today.
Katrina:  哈哈哈到时候死都没想到
Katrina: Hahaha, I wouldn't have imagined it even in my wildest dreams.
Shure:  我听到了你的闹钟
Shure: I heard your alarm.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina:  不是你怎么听到
Katrina: How did you hear it?
Katrina:  你不是住一楼吗
Katrina: Aren't you living on the first floor?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  因为咱俩应该就是差不多上上下这种
Shure: Because we're kind of like above and below each other.
Shure:  啊你那个跟我是一样的
Shure: Ah, yours is just like mine.
Lucia: 不过也正常
Lucia: But it's normal.
Lucia: 我我我本科舍友回我早晨定的闹铃
Lucia: My undergrad roommate would set an alarm in the morning.
Lucia: 我舍友都醒了
Lucia: My roommate would wake up.
Lucia: 我自己还没醒
Lucia: But I still wouldn't be awake myself.
Shure: 自己就听不见
Shure: You just can't hear it yourself.
Katrina:  嗯明天定三个
Katrina: Hmm, I'll set three alarms tomorrow.
Katrina:  那就差不多想想啊
Katrina: That should do the trick.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 所以那一天的甜品是要当天做
Jake: So, does the dessert need to be made on the same day?
Jake: 还是可以前一天做
Jake: Or can it be made the day before?
Tasha: 有的需要冷藏的会前一天做
Tasha: Some that need to be refrigerated are made the day before.
Tasha: 比如提拉米苏
Tasha: Like Tiramisu.
Katrina:  哎其实像那种
Katrina: Oh, actually, things like that.
Katrina:  就是我看他们那种清补凉那种
Katrina: I see them making that kind of Ching Po Leung.
Katrina:  是不是就买点椰奶然后做点圆
Katrina: They just buy some coconut milk and make some balls.
Tasha: 清补凉的话那是不是好调一点啊
Tasha: For Ching Po Leung, isn't it easier to prepare?
Tasha: 也是前一天做好
Tasha: Also made the day before.
Tasha: 然后第二天就直接把原料
Tasha: Then the next day, just use the ingredients.
Tasha: 然后进行一个配就行
Tasha: And just mix them together.
Tasha: 对对对就是用那个吉利丁片和椰奶
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, just use gelatine sheets and coconut milk.
Tasha: 就可以做
Tasha: That would work.
Tasha: 好像
Tasha: I think.
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina:  我看他们有的那种糖水就是直接椰奶
Katrina: I see them making some of those desserts with just coconut milk.
Katrina:  然后加一点水果
Katrina: And then adding some fruit.
Katrina:  加一点芋圆就行了
Katrina: And adding some taro balls.
Katrina:  感觉那样会不会简单一点
Katrina: That seems simpler.
Katrina:  就不要做成那种冻不起的那种
Katrina: Without making it into a jelly.
Katrina:  就不要用那个什么吉利饮片
Katrina: So we don't need to use gelatine sheets.
Tasha: 那清补凉好吃吗你觉得
Tasha: Do you think Ching Po Leung tastes good?
Katrina:  我觉得随便
Katrina: I think it's fine.
Katrina:  就是我感觉会不会简单一点那种吗
Katrina: I feel like it might be a bit simpler?
Tasha: 他说不要液体不要固体的啊
Tasha: He said no liquids, no solids.
Katrina:  就是直接就像那种水牛奶一样的
Katrina: Just something like water or milk.
Katrina:  因为我自己经常喝的糖水
Katrina: Because I often drink sugar water.
Katrina:  我看他们就是一点椰奶啊
Katrina: I see they use a bit of coconut milk,
Katrina:  然后芒果然后一些那个红豆
Katrina: then mango, and some red beans.
Katrina:  就就这样配就很快
Katrina: Just mix it like that, it's quick.
Katrina:  嗯就是芋圆可能要熬一下
Katrina: Hmm, but the taro balls might need to be cooked a bit.
Katrina:  椰果呢都能现买耶
Katrina: You can buy coconut jelly easily.
Katrina:  随便看你看你吧
Katrina: It's up to you, whatever you prefer.
Katrina:  你说什么就是什么
Katrina: Whatever you say goes.
Katrina:  你准备了芋圆的东西吗
Katrina: Did you prepare the taro balls?
Tasha: 芋圆我
Tasha: Taro balls, I...
Tasha: 我没有买芋圆材料
Tasha: I didn't buy the ingredients for taro balls.
Katrina:  芋圆是不是可以直接买
Katrina: Can we buy ready-made taro balls?
Lucia: 芋圆也有成品吧
Lucia: There are ready-made ones, right?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Katrina: 直接买成品
Katrina: Just buy the ready-made ones.
Katrina:  那我看看
Katrina: Let me check.
Katrina:  4:20介绍完以后
Katrina: After the 4:20 introduction,
Katrina:  要有一个品尝甜品的时间
Katrina: there should be a dessert tasting time.
Katrina:  那是不是要到4点
Katrina: So, it should be around 4.
Katrina:  4:35开始
Katrina: Starts at 4:35.
Katrina:  但是我到5点多
Katrina: But I’ll be there until past 5,
Katrina:  然后就开始吃晚饭晚饭
Katrina: then we start dinner.
Katrina:  就是gas part之后我们就收眼镜传数据
Katrina: After the gas part, we'll collect the glasses and transfer data.
Jake: 对对对然后吃饭就不录
Jake: Yeah, yeah, and we won't record while eating.
Katrina: 吃饭就不录
Katrina: We won't record while eating.
Jake: 吃饭不录
Jake: No recording during dinner.
Tasha: 那那晚饭是自己做吗
Tasha: So, are we cooking dinner ourselves?
Katrina:  晚饭就那个点披萨嘛
Katrina: Dinner is just ordering pizza.
Jake:晚饭大披萨
Jake: Dinner, big pizza.
Katrina:  然后一些烧烤
Katrina: And some BBQ.
Jake:大披萨对
Jake: Big pizza, yeah.
Jake: 烧烤也不能录烧烤把
Jake: We can't record the BBQ either.
Jake: 眼镜给烧坏了
Jake: The glasses might get damaged.
Katrina:  哦对
Katrina: Oh, right.
Katrina:  没事刚好那那一个小时
Katrina: No problem, then for that hour,
Katrina:  那你就传数据
Katrina: you can transfer data.
Shure: 订一个披萨得了
Shure: Let's just order a pizza.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  BBQ再说
Shure: We can do BBQ later.
Shure:  barbecue可以咱们咱们这两天自个吃
Shure: We can have BBQ ourselves in the next couple of days.
Jake:五点到六点
Jake: From 5 to 6.
Jake: 啊什么东西
Jake: What did you say?
Jake: 芭比q自己吃是吗
Jake: BBQ for ourselves, right?
Lucia: 那个是烧烤炉吗
Lucia: Is that a grill?
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, it is.
Lucia: 哦还挺大
Lucia: Oh, it's quite big.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  然后人太多的话
Shure: If there are too many people,
Shure:  芭比q真的不好不好玩
Shure: BBQ isn't really fun.
Alice: 特别慢
Alice: It's super slow.
Jake:嗯嗯嗯 那就不要芭比q
Jake: Yeah, yeah, let's skip the BBQ then.
Jake: 没关系或者给他整两串得了
Jake: No problem, or we can just make a few skewers.
Lucia:  意思意思
Lucia: Just for the gesture.
Katrina: 点吧点吧都是我自己烤的
Katrina: Go ahead, order. I'll be the one grilling them anyway.
Jake: 对对对问就是有
Jake: Yeah, yeah, just say we have it.
Jake:问就是有
Jake: Just say we have it.
Lucia: 可以对可以点进来然后到时候再拿出去说是烤的
Lucia: Yeah, we can order it in and then take it out saying it's grilled.
Shure:  对碳咱们只买碳然后热一下
Shure: Yeah, we just buy the charcoal and heat it up.
Jake:哦哦妙啊
Jake: Oh, that's clever.
Jake: 挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Lucia: 有西餐厅那种圆的那样罩住
Lucia: Like those round covers in Western restaurants.
Lucia: 要不然话
Lucia: Otherwise,
Lucia: 大家就会发现
Lucia: People will notice.
Lucia: 你这个拿出来的时候
Lucia: When you take it out,
Lucia: 就已经是烤好的了
Lucia: It's already grilled.
Lucia: 然后就这样挡一下
Lucia: Just cover it up.
Lucia: 然后放在炉上烤一烤
Lucia: And put it on the grill.
Lucia: 说是刚烤的
Lucia: Say it's freshly grilled.
Jake:是是是
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  太天才了
Shure: That's genius.
Jake: 对一分钟考好
Jake: Yeah, grilled in a minute.
Katrina:  那就我们的那个活动就6点半到8点
Katrina: So our event will be from 6:30 to 8.
Katrina:  节目唱唱歌跳舞
Katrina: Singing and dancing.
Katrina:  一个半小时够了再长弄不下去了
Katrina: An hour and a half should be enough, any longer and it's too much.
Shure:  free time对大家可以表演一个半小时
Shure: Free time, everyone can perform for an hour and a half.
Shure:  然后我们可以auction拆出来也行
Shure: Then we can auction things off too.
Shure:  就是比如说没进行完有的人没拍
Shure: For example, if some people didn't finish filming
Shure:  卖 完然后晚饭之后接着
Shure: they can continue after dinner.
Katrina: 可以继续想分享的
Katrina: They can continue sharing if they want to.
Lucia: 对大家自由的交换
Lucia: Yes, everyone can exchange freely.
Jake:哦哦也行也行
Jake: Sure, that works.
Lucia: 嗯反正一般等家务已经有了
Lucia: Yeah, usually after housework is done.
Katrina:  那就是5点半开饭然后6点半
Katrina: So, dinner at 5:30, and then 6:30...
Tasha: 那如果我要走了钱没花完怎么办
Tasha: What if I have to leave and haven't spent all my money?
Jake: 哈哈哈人死了钱没花完
Jake: Hahaha, if the person dies without spending all the money...
Jake: 什么什么钱没花完
Jake: What, what money isn't spent?
Shure:  就是那个硬币
Shure: Just the coins.
Tasha: 硬币啊
Tasha: Coins?
Jake: 硬币在
Jake: The coins are still there.
Shure: 我们要控制好这个通货
Shure: We need to control this currency.
Katrina: 我们把我们的送给他们
Katrina: We can give ours to them.
Jake: 对对对送俩充电宝吧 要不
Jake: Yeah, yeah, give them two power banks, maybe?
Katrina: 送点充电宝
Katrina: Give them some power banks.
Tasha: 这挺好的
Tasha: That sounds good.
Katrina:  还可以反正最后一天了
Katrina: Anyway, it's the last day.
Katrina:  你是不是也不太
Katrina: You don't really...
Jake:对对 是的是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Katrina: 抽奖环节
Katrina: Raffle session.
Lucia: 那我到时候也可以买一个充电宝
Lucia: Then I can buy a power bank too.
Katrina:  我们学院每次晚会都送充电宝
Katrina: Our college gives out power banks at every party.
Lucia:  我们也是
Lucia: Same here.
Lucia: 我们招聘会也会送充电宝
Lucia: We give out power banks at job fairs too.
Jake: 哦原因找到了是吧
Jake: Oh, that's the reason, right?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  可以那就把充电宝送出去
Katrina: Okay, let's give out the power banks.
Tasha: 只要来就可以送一个充电宝
Tasha: Anyone who comes can get a power bank.
Katrina:  看他们手上有
Katrina: Look, they already have them.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Shure:  那个好像没有没有没有没有插上
Shure: That one isn't plugged in.
Shure:  没有插上
Shure: It's not plugged in.
Shure:  嗯好这回插上
Shure: Okay, it's plugged in now.
Jake: 哎呀你这个没电了
Jake: Oh no, it's out of battery.
Shure:  已经没了
Shure: It's dead already.
Jake: 你这已经断掉了
Jake: Yours is already disconnected.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  重新录一下
Shure: Record it again.
Jake: 对你你得
Jake: Yeah, you need to.
Jake: 没关系就是我们重新看一遍时间就行
Jake: It's okay, we just need to check the time again.
Shure: 好了现在好了因为
Shure: Okay, it's good now because...
Katrina:   我的亮吗
Katrina: Is mine on?
Lucia: 它亮着呢
Lucia: It's on.
Jake: 你再重新开一下
Jake: Restart it again.
Shure:  素材丢失
Shure: The footage is lost.
Jake: 稍有丢失问题不大
Jake: Slight loss is not a big deal.
Katrina:  那你你的那part的东西买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy your part's stuff?
Lucia: 我们取决于我们要做什么
Lucia: It depends on what we're making.
Lucia: 我要买水母
Lucia: I want to buy jellyfish.
Lucia: 不是如果要买水母灯
Lucia: No, if we need to buy jellyfish lights.
Lucia: 如果要做水母灯的话
Lucia: If we're making jellyfish lights.
Lucia: 大家是想用材料包做还是
Lucia: Do we want to use a materials kit or...
Lucia: 就是那种循环利用的做
Lucia: Use recycled materials?
Katrina:  什么叫循环利用的做
Katrina: What do you mean by recycled materials?
Katrina:  就是拿那个
Katrina: Like using...
Lucia: 呃叫什么奶茶盖那种
Lucia: Uh, like bubble tea lids.
Lucia: 虽然奶茶盖其实我也没做过
Lucia: Although I haven't done it with bubble tea lids before.
Lucia: 我之前做过材料包
Lucia: I used a materials kit before.
Katrina:  奶茶盖的话那是不是得买奶茶呀
Katrina: If we use bubble tea lids, do we need to buy bubble tea?
Lucia: 确实啊我们可以买个奶茶盖哦
Lucia: True, we can buy a bubble tea lid.
Jake: 好没问题
Jake: Sure, no problem.
Lucia: 然后它其实材料还蛮简单的
Lucia: The materials are actually quite simple.
Lucia: 就丝带和串珠这些就行
Lucia: Just ribbons and beads.
Katrina:  那可以直接买材料包了
Katrina: Then we can just buy a materials kit.
Lucia: 买材料包的话好像就没有那种
Lucia: If we buy a materials kit, it won't have that...
Katrina: 环保的
Katrina: Eco-friendly.
Lucia: 对特别环保的概念体现
Lucia: Yeah, the eco-friendly concept.
Katrina:  那就那就得喝奶茶了哈哈
Katrina: Then we'll just have to drink bubble tea, haha.
Lucia: 或者也可以
Lucia: Or we could...
Lucia: 应该应该
Lucia: Maybe...
Lucia: 淘宝上有那种包装
Lucia: They might have some on Taobao.
Lucia: 也可以买一个我看看
Lucia: We can buy one, let me check.
Katrina:  但是你买包装跟买材料包感觉差不多意思
Katrina: But buying a package and buying a materials kit feels the same.
Lucia: 但是就是
Lucia: But it's just...
Lucia: 至少它给人的视觉效果是环保的
Lucia: At least it gives an eco-friendly visual effect.
Lucia: 至于它流
Lucia: As for its flow
Lucia: 程中这个就我们自行控制
Lucia: We can control this ourselves during the process
Katrina:  那应该没啥问题了
Katrina: Then there shouldn't be any problem
Katrina:  然后可能嗯
Katrina: And then maybe, um
Katrina:  如果要唱歌那种音响话筒这音调节
Katrina: If we need to sing, we should adjust the sound system and microphone
Jake: 我们之前让GPT出了几个plan
Jake: Earlier, we had GPT come up with a few plans
Jake: 嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm
Jake:环保版 你你说你画我猜
Jake: The eco-friendly version of the "Draw and Guess" game
Katrina: 这个小游戏呢可以设置在
Katrina: This little game can be set up in
Jake: 参与者
Jake: Participants
Jake: 啊对参与者分组
Jake: Ah yes, participants are grouped
Jake: 每组选择一个环保词汇
Jake: Each group chooses an eco-friendly word
Jake: 如太阳能
Jake: Like solar energy
Jake: 零废弃
Jake: Zero waste
Jake: 用肢体
Jake: Using gestures
Tasha:  该怎么表达
Tasha: How to express it
Shure:  就是这种特别抽象的
Shure: It's very abstract
Shure:  然后大家就不好画
Shure: So it's hard for everyone to draw
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 只能画吗
Lucia: Can only draw?
Lucia: 不能描述吗
Lucia: Can't describe it?
Jake: 画画
Jake: Drawing only
Jake: 啊不能说话了
Jake: Ah, no talking
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm
Katrina:  那就设置在晚上吧
Katrina: Then let's set it up in the evening
Jake:太阳能
Jake: Solar energy
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay
Katrina:  下午的时间不是很多
Katrina: We don't have much time in the afternoon
Katrina:  下午3点开始到5点半
Katrina: It starts at 3 PM and ends at 5:30 PM
Katrina:  就两个半小时
Katrina: Just two and a half hours
Katrina:  介绍介绍
Katrina: A brief introduction
Katrina:  逛一逛就差不多了
Katrina: And a little tour should be enough
Jake: 嗯还有一个更离谱的
Jake: Mm, there's an even wilder idea
Jake: 他的GPT确实厉害
Jake: GPT is really impressive
Jake: 在沙盘或沙地中
Jake: In a sandbox or sand area
Jake: 隐藏一些微型塑料颗粒
Jake: Hide some tiny plastic particles
Jake: 参与者使用镊子和放大镜
Jake: Participants use tweezers and magnifying glasses
Jake: 在规定时间内
Jake: Within a set time
Jake: 尽可能找出这些塑料颗粒
Jake: To find as many plastic particles as possible
Jake: 哈哈这个游戏
Jake: Haha, this game is fun
Jake: 这个游戏
Jake: This game
Jake: 可以让大家直观的认识到
Jake: can let everyone directly understand
Jake: 微塑料污染的隐蔽性
Jake: the hidden nature of microplastic pollution.
Jake: 哈哈哈很妙
Jake: Haha, it's pretty clever.
Jake: 这个GPT就是使唤人
Jake: This GPT just orders people around.
Jake: AI使唤人挺能整
Jake: AI ordering people around is quite something.
Shure:  完了你可不能像他学
Shure: Don't you dare learn from it.
Shure:  听没听到
Shure: Did you hear me?
Lucia: 寻废品对
Lucia: Looking for scrap, right.
Jake: 对而且你这个头发还是遮住了
Jake: Yeah, and your hair is still covering it.
Jake: 要不还是我们
Jake: Why don't we just
Shure: 我我我们下下下午对采购一波发卡
Shure: We'll go shopping for some hairpins this afternoon.
Jake: 我们下午下午采购一波
Jake: We'll go shopping this afternoon.
Jake: 采购一波对
Jake: Go shopping, right.
Katrina:  下午要去采购是吗
Katrina: We need to go shopping this afternoon, right?
Tasha:  这个吗
Tasha: This one?
Shure:  对就是这种
Shure: Yeah, just like this.
Shure:  这种小别的那种
Shure: This kind of small one.
Jake: 我们再看一圈吧
Jake: Let's take another look around.
Jake: 我们其实不用
Jake: We actually don't need to,
Jake: 但是也看一眼
Jake: but let's just take a look.
Lucia: 哎停住了
Lucia: Oh, it stopped.
Jake: 哎呀完了
Jake: Oh no, it's over.
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over.
Jake: 没事
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 我们其实剩下的一个人就行
Jake: Actually, one person left is fine.
Jake: 但是就转一圈比较稳妥
Jake: But it's safer to take another round.
Katrina:  我发现这名片好好看
Katrina: I found this business card so pretty.
Shure:  哦你们看那个你想活出怎样的人生
Shure: Oh, did you watch "What Kind of Life Do You Want to Live"?
Shure:  关崎骏那个
Shure: The one by Hayao Miyazaki.
Katrina:  看没看懂
Katrina: Did you understand it?
Katrina:  后来看解析
Katrina: Later, I watched the analysis.
Katrina:  了回来看解析
Katrina: I watched the analysis later.
Katrina:  应该先看解析再去看
Katrina: You should watch the analysis first and then watch it.
Shure:  那些数字
Shure: Those numbers...
Alice: 他只有5%的电正充着电
Alice: He only has 5% battery left, it's charging.
Alice: 他不会充的没用的快吧
Alice: It won't charge up fast enough, right?
Jake: 呃不会不会不会不会
Jake: Uh, no, no, no, no.
Shure:  只要抱着太紧了就可以
Shure: As long as you hold on tightly, it's fine.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  OK那这就差不多敲定了
Katrina: Okay, then it's pretty much settled.
Jake: 差不多了那我们看看要准备什么吧
Jake: Almost. Let's see what we need to prepare.
Jake: 这七天
Jake: These seven days...
Katrina:  嗯我想想啊就是各自买各自的材料
Katrina: Hmm, let me think. We each buy our own materials.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  然后要有音响和话筒如果要唱歌的话
Katrina: And then we need speakers and microphones if we're going to sing.
Shure:  这个我都能搞定
Shure: I can handle that.
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Katrina:  啊你本来就乐队的是吧
Katrina: Oh, you were in a band, right?
Jake: 你可以把音乐队都给弄来
Jake: You can bring the whole band.
Katrina:  我们当时就也总是那乐队同学带音响
Katrina: We always had our bandmates bring the sound system back then.
Shure:  这这算商演吧应该
Shure: This should be considered a commercial performance.
Jake: 商演商演商演
Jake: Commercial performance, commercial performance.
Katrina:  商演商演商演
Katrina: Commercial performance, commercial performance.
Jake: 学术商演学术商演学术商演
Jake: Academic commercial performance, academic commercial performance.
Shure: 学术商演
Shure: Academic commercial performance.
Jake: 在学术会议上面商演演唱会算什么呀
Jake: What does it mean to have a concert at an academic conference?
Jake: 你们接过这种活吗
Jake: Have you ever taken such a gig?
Shure:  之前邀邀请过但是没没去
Shure: We were invited before, but we didn't go.
Jake:昂没去
Jake: Oh, you didn't go.
Shure:   有点太尴尬了主要是
Shure: It was too awkward, mainly.
Jake: 哦这下面人在看pose呢
Jake: Oh, people down there watching poses.
Jake: 然后你在这敲锣打鼓
Jake: And you guys are making a ruckus.
Shure:  对对啊多尬呀我靠
Shure: Yeah, it's super awkward, damn.
Katrina:  他那个呃你们买了什么
Katrina: So, what did you guys buy?
Katrina:  支架和小桌子吗
Katrina: Stands and small tables?
Jake: 嗯我们要不看看快递
Jake: Hmm, should we check the deliveries?
Jake: 或者我们到处看一看吧
Jake: Or we can look around.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 因为这个房间我们可能也要收拾收拾
Jake: Because we might need to tidy up this room.
Jake: 装饰装饰
Jake: Decorate it.
Jake:就是这个屋子
Jake: This room...
Katrina:  哦这个那我们是不是
Katrina: Oh, so should we...
Katrina:  如果你要世界地球日为主题
Katrina: If you want an Earth Day theme,
Katrina:  要买一点贴画呀
Katrina: We need to buy some stickers.
Jake: 对对对是的
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Jake: 但是这个墙不能贴
Jake: But we can't stick them on the wall.
Jake: 我们也得想想办法怎么搞
Jake: We need to figure out a way to do it.
Katrina:  有那种无痕贴的挂钩
Katrina: There's that kind of hook with no trace adhesive.
Jake: 就是他就不不能贴这种墙
Jake: But it can't be stuck on this kind of wall.
Katrina:  我知道
Katrina: I know.
Katrina:  我姐结婚的时候他们就是那种贴的
Katrina: When my sister got married, they used that kind of adhesive.
Katrina:  就是酒店贴的
Katrina: It was at the hotel.
Katrina:  可以撕下来就完全无痕的
Katrina: You can peel it off without any traces.
Jake: OKOK如果很稳妥的话可以不然的话赔钱
Jake: OK, OK, if it's really secure, we can use it. Otherwise, we'll have to pay for the damages.
Jake: 赔不起 哈哈哈对这样砍了有多稳妥
Jake: We can't afford it, haha. Yeah, how secure is it?
Katrina:  然后还有就是我们每个人的东西的话
Katrina: And also, for each of our things...
Katrina:  他的甜品有自己的甜品家
Katrina: His desserts have their own display area.
Katrina:  那我们每个人
Katrina: So each of us...
Katrina:  东西是不是也要有装桌子摆摊
Katrina: Should we also have a table to display our stuff?
Jake: 嗯可以啊桌子
Jake: Hmm, yeah, a table is fine.
Katrina:  因为那天
Katrina: Because that day...
Shure: 去宜家采购一波吧
Shure: Let's go on a shopping spree at IKEA.
Katrina:  20多人
Katrina: Over 20 people.
Jake:哈哈哈过分了
Jake: Haha, that's too much.
Lucia: 直接给别墅主人添新家具
Lucia: We'll just be adding new furniture for the villa owner.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 一个够吗
Lucia: Is one enough?
Lucia: 还是要多买两个
Lucia: Or should we buy two more?
Katrina:  你这一个是就是多少人可以一起玩
Katrina: How many people can play with this at the same time?
Shure:  大概就一个人一起玩
Shure: Probably just one person.
Lucia: 哈哈哈两三个应该也行再多是不是可能
Lucia: Haha, two or three should be fine. More than that might be too much.
Shure:  再多其实买3个差不多
Shure: Actually, buying three should be about right.
Jake: 我们要不玩一下
Jake: Why don't we play a bit?
Jake: 怎么玩
Jake: How do we play?
Lucia: 啊对我们先来试验一下
Lucia: Ah, right, let's test it out first.
Shure:  我们这些这些都得试验一遍
Shure: We should test all of these.
Shure:  就是甜品我们得先先吃一遍
Shure: For example, we should try all the desserts first.
Jake:对对对对
Jake: Right, right, right.
Katrina: 彩排
Katrina: Rehearsal.
Shure:  然后烧烤也得先吃一遍
Shure: And we should also try the barbecue.
Lucia: 算盘打的
Lucia: Calculating it all...
Alice: 这是一个支架的就不用管它
Alice: This is a stand, so we don't need to worry about it.
Shure:  毕竟其实这个比点外卖会便宜一些
Shure: After all, this is actually cheaper than ordering takeout.
Tasha: 什么会比点外卖便宜
Tasha: What is cheaper than ordering takeout?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Shure:  就是比如说自己搞顿烧烤
Shure: Like, making our own barbecue.
Shure:  比点一桌子这样的烤串肯定会便宜
Shure: It's definitely cheaper than ordering a whole table of skewers.
Jake: 嗯那是这烧烤卖的可贵了
Jake: Hmm, this barbecue is sold at quite a high price.
Jake:一根啥也不是
Jake: One stick is practically nothing.
Shure:  是一串四五块钱哦
Shure: It's like four or five bucks per skewer.
Shure: 啪
Shure: Wham.
Alice: 挺多
Alice: That's a lot.
Jake: 哦看起来很难拼到吧
Jake: Oh, it looks like it's hard to piece together.
Alice: 确实不太好拼比较费时间
Alice: It’s really not easy to piece together; it takes a lot of time.
Tasha: 要怎么拼
Tasha: How do you piece it?
Jake: 就把它给拼成一个圆啊
Jake: You just piece it into a circle.
Jake: 你要fit进去边缘
Jake: You need to fit it along the edge.
Shure:  这种弧形的都应该在边边
Shure: These curved pieces should be on the edges.
Jake: 他有可能骗你的吧
Jake: He might be tricking you.
Jake: 有会有可能吧
Jake: It’s possible, right?
Tasha: 哎你这个明显就不在边边你这个
Tasha: Hey, this piece obviously isn't on the edge.
Alice:所以
Alice: So...
Tasha: 不对
Tasha: That's not right.
Jake: 毫无头绪
Jake: Absolutely clueless.
Jake: 一个都找不到
Jake: Can’t find a single piece.
Lucia: 这个应该是在边边的这个
Lucia: This piece should be on the edge.
Shure:  这个某一个边
Shure: This one is on some edge.
Jake:一个吻合的都找不到麻
Jake: Can’t find one that fits.
Shure:  对一个边是在边边的
Shure: Yeah, one edge is on the edge.
Lucia: 这个好像也能贴上
Lucia: This one seems to fit too.
Shure:  这不完全OK
Shure: This isn’t completely OK.
Jake: 他是一定会完全还是他他就会
Jake: Is it supposed to be a perfect fit or what?
Katrina:  这个很适合放在安全性那边
Katrina: This is perfect for the safety section.
Katrina:  让大家熟悉起来
Katrina: To get everyone familiar.
Jake: 昂 对 有那种特别大的吗就是
Jake: Yeah, are there really big pieces?
Katrina:  这几个人坐在一起
Katrina: With a few people sitting together.
Katrina: 玩一把就熟
Katrina: They’ll get it after one go.
Tasha: 我感觉这个是这样子的是吧
Tasha: I feel like it's like this, right?
Jake:昂ok
Jake: Yeah, OK.
Lucia: 很有可能
Lucia: Very likely.
Shure:  哎呦
Shure: Ouch.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Shure:  屌的嘞
Shure: Awesome.
Lucia: 感觉应该是看起来很
Lucia: It should look like it's very...
Lucia: 就是密合程度是比较高的
Lucia: The degree of fit is quite high.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 那这个就是哎有可能
Lucia: So this is... it’s possible.
Tasha: 天才三位天才诞生
Tasha: Three geniuses, three geniuses are born.
Shure: 洒洒水啦
Shure: Piece of cake.
Shure:  这不两分钟搞定啊
Shure: Didn't we finish this in two minutes?
Lucia: 这里是缺一个什么呢啊
Lucia: What's missing here?
Shure: 缺个脚比较啊
Shure: Missing a leg comparison.
Alice: 哦不是完全拼合的
Alice: Oh, it's not completely aligned.
Alice: 还是有一点点缝缝的
Alice: There's still a bit of a gap.
Tasha: 不对
Tasha: No, that's not right.
Alice:  看一下答案吗
Alice: Should we check the answer?
Shure:  不需要开玩笑
Shure: No need, are you kidding?
Jake:不要不要太早了太早了太早了
Jake: No, no, too early, too early, too early.
Alice:就是你也记不住啊
Alice: It's not like you'll remember it anyway.
Jake: 没有没有我们能拼出来
Jake: No, no, we can figure it out.
Jake: 能拼出来
Jake: We can figure it out.
Shure:  我们看答案
Shure: Let's check the answer.
Shure:  开什么玩笑
Shure: Just kidding.
Lucia: 不错我觉得这个游戏参与度还是很高的
Lucia: Not bad, I think this game has high participation.
Alice:不是你
Alice: Not you.
Alice: 反正你也记不住
Alice: You can't remember it anyway.
Lucia: 我刚刚看到了跟他很像的在这里
Lucia: I just saw something similar to it here.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina:  嵌不进去差一点点
Katrina: It doesn't fit, just a tiny bit off.
Jake: 嗯怎么一个靠谱的都找不到呢
Jake: Hmm, why can't we find a reliable one?
Jake: 哈哈哈这算吗这个
Jake: Hahaha, does this count?
Katrina: 他中间应该不是严丝合缝把
Katrina: It shouldn't fit perfectly in the middle.
Lucia: 这是不是
Lucia: Is this it?
Jake: 对他不是严丝合缝但是
Jake: Yeah, it's not a perfect fit, but...
Katrina:  如果严丝合缝就很好找啊
Katrina: If it fits perfectly, it'd be easy to find.
Katrina:  找那个不同的
Katrina: Look for the different one.
Jake:他有可能有很多解法
Jake: There could be many solutions.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake: 毫无头绪
Jake: No clue at all.
Jake: 这可能就啥也没有啊
Jake: Maybe there's nothing here at all.
Jake: 逗你玩
Jake: Just messing with you.
Tasha: 我觉得都没有一圈怎么回事
Tasha: I don't think there's even a circle, what's going on?
Jake: 对啊他面积都不够啊
Jake: Yeah, the area isn't enough.
Jake: 对我们要不直接往里面放吧
Jake: Yeah, let's just put it inside directly.
Jake: 你看能不能
Jake: See if you can.
Shure: 完了
Shure: We're doomed.
Shure: 急了有人急了
Shure: Someone's getting anxious.
Jake: 不是不是不是不是
Jake: No, no, no, no.
Jake: 往里面放看看面积
Jake: Put it inside and see the area.
Lucia: 面积可能还是差不多的吧
Lucia: The area might still be about the same.
Lucia: 看起来
Lucia: It looks like it.
Lucia: 就是这还有一些就感觉可能是差不多的
Lucia: There's still some here, so it feels like it's probably about the same.
Lucia: 哎这是猫头鹰
Lucia: Hey, it's an owl!
Lucia: 好可爱哦
Lucia: So cute!
Shure:  有人急了呀
Shure: Someone's getting anxious.
Alice: 这样看起来几个人一起玩也可以
Alice: It looks like several people could play together.
Jake: 是的是的挺好的这个东西
Jake: Yes, yes, this thing is pretty good.
Shure:  这也不是严丝合缝
Shure: It's not a perfect fit.
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: So hard!
Jake: 是什么东西
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 是小老鼠吗
Lucia: Is it a little mouse?
Lucia: 青蛙土地公公
Lucia: A frog Earth God?
Shure:  哈哈哈哈咱们是野生动物
Shure: Hahaha, we're talking about wild animals.
Shure:  不是神话故事
Shure: Not mythological stories.
Shure:  还土地公公
Shure: Earth God, really?
Jake: 野生神仙
Jake: A wild deity.
Lucia: 野生
Lucia: Wild.
Katrina:  特别像一个表情包
Katrina: It looks just like a meme.
Jake: 没有
Jake: No.
Tasha: 怎么又不亮了
Tasha: Why isn't it lighting up again?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me see.
Shure: 是那边没插上
Shure: It's not plugged in over there.
Lucia: 这个也不是耶
Lucia: This one isn't either.
Lucia: 奇怪
Lucia: Weird.
Alice: 但是他一直
Alice: But it always...
Alice: 是35的电
Alice: It has 35 power.
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Alice: 就没有
Alice: And then it doesn't.
Katrina:  我也是一直35
Katrina: Mine is always 35 too.
Jake: 对他电很多
Jake: Yes, it has a lot of power.
Lucia: 嗯不是
Lucia: Hmm, no.
Shure:  他是一个2万毫安时
Shure: It's a 20,000 mAh battery.
Jake: 我看一下你的这个APP
Jake: Let me check your app.
Tasha: 我觉得这个是这样子
Tasha: I think it's like this.
Katrina:  就是那软件吗
Katrina: Is it the software?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 这个是不是这样子
Tasha: Is it supposed to be like this?
Jake:四十三
Jake: Forty-three.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:但是他显示待记录啊
Alice: But it shows "Pending record."
Jake:charge charge就对了
Jake: 我看一下看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake: 我是l你是L2是吗
Jake: I'm L1, you're L2, right?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 嗯怎么回事
Jake: Hmm, what's going on?
Jake: 灯坏了呵呵呵
Jake: The light's broken, haha.
Alice: 他在录但是
Alice: It's recording, but...
Lucia: 他是就是是不是自动
Lucia: Is it automatic?
Lucia: 自动监测
Lucia: Automatic monitoring?
Lucia: 觉得现在这个环境不需要开灯
Lucia: Maybe it thinks the current environment doesn't need the light.
Jake: 没有不是不是不是这个
Jake: No, no, that's not it.
Jake: 这个是为了保护被拍摄人的隐私就是
Jake: This is to protect the privacy of the person being recorded.
Jake: 被拍摄人知道自己
Jake: So the person being recorded knows...
Alice:提示你你被录了
Alice: To inform you that you're being recorded.
Jake: 对对对是的
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Jake: 但是其实拍摄人不知道
Jake: But actually, the cameraman didn't know.
Jake: 但是呵呵
Jake: But, hehe.
Jake: 拍摄人应该会感觉到吧
Jake: The cameraman should have felt it, right?
Lucia: 啊了胜于无
Lucia: Ah, better than nothing.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 再输一下
Jake: Try again.
Jake:他  刚刚其实是软件没有更新你的状态
Jake: Just now, the software didn't update your status.
Jake: 所以你是没有在录
Jake: So you weren't recording.
Jake: 但是软件上也是我在录
Jake: But on the software, it showed I was recording.
Jake: 这另外的
Jake: This is another one.
Alice:我按照现在的时间吧
Alice: I'll go by the current time.
Jake:实在
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia: 所以这个到底是什么
Lucia: So, what is this exactly?
Lucia: 他有5个角哎
Lucia: It has five corners.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Uh, yeah.
Jake: 你按照现在的时间
Jake: You go by the current time.
Lucia: 神奇
Lucia: Amazing.
Jake: 这个哈哈哈估计最后才能放吧
Jake: This, hahaha, probably can only be shown at the end.
Jake: 这是大嘴鸟是吧
Jake: Is this a toucan?
Tasha: 哦我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia: 好抽象啊
Lucia: So abstract.
Jake: 大嘴鸟
Jake: Toucan.
Jake: 这个也很抽象
Jake: This is also very abstract.
Jake: 谁家牛长这样
Jake: Whose cow looks like this?
Shure:  野牛啊水牛
Shure: A wild buffalo or water buffalo.
Jake: 那水牛为什么下面会长稻草
Jake: Then why does the water buffalo have straw underneath it?
Alice: 他站在草上
Alice: It's standing on grass.
Shure:  毛很长这个这个
Shure: The hair is very long, this, this...
Lucia: 这个是不是他这一边
Lucia: Is this his side?
Lucia: 是哎对
Lucia: Yes, it is.
Shure:  他叫牦牛
Shure: It's called a yak.
Jake: 对这个很妙
Jake: Yes, this is amazing.
Jake: 嗯这个太妙了
Jake: Hmm, this is really amazing.
Lucia: 然后既然是这一边的话
Lucia: And since it's this side...
Lucia: 那这里应该有一个能放的东西
Lucia: There should be something you can place here.
Alice: 尖尖的
Alice: Something sharp.
Lucia: 好像不是耶
Lucia: Seems like it's not.
Shure:  不是CPU白烧了
Shure: If not, the CPU would be wasted.
Shure:  AI快给我一个解法
Shure: AI, quickly give me a solution.
Jake: 大家一直在看时间
Jake: Everyone's been watching the time.
Jake: 看秒表这个数据
Jake: Looking at the stopwatch data.
Katrina:  看这个是为了干啥
Katrina: What's the point of looking at this?
Jake: 为了同步
Jake: To synchronize.
Jake: 回头就是在某一个帧上面把时间写上
Jake: Later, we'll write the time on a specific frame.
Katrina:  哦明白了
Katrina: Oh, got it.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: This is so hard.
Jake: 这个会在边上吗
Jake: Will this be at the edge?
Jake: 还有没有边了
Jake: Is there any edge left?
Lucia: 这个边怎么给人一种不太够的感觉
Lucia: Why does this edge feel like it's not enough?
Alice: 他这不是严丝合缝
Alice: It's not perfectly aligned.
Alice: 有的是差不多的那种
Alice: Some are just approximately fitting.
Alice: 嗯这回是比较不太像
Alice: Hmm, this time it doesn't look quite right.
Jake: 放回去吧要不还是全放进去吧
Jake: Let's put it back, or just put everything in.
Jake: 哈哈全放进去
Jake: Haha, put everything in.
Jake: 先看一看他乱拼的话能差多少
Jake: Let's see how much it will differ if we randomly piece it together.
Tasha: 这只鸟好占位
Tasha: This bird takes up so much space.
Katrina:  所有的都可以放进去
Katrina: Everything can fit in.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Jake: 刚刚就是这么拿出来的是吧
Jake: That's how you took it out, right?
Shure:  不是用来比那个大的总面积
Shure: It's not used to compare the total area.
Alice:他就不是严丝合缝有的是差不多的那种
Alice: It's not a perfect fit, it's more like a close match.
Jake:哦哦哦OK
Jake: Oh oh oh, OK.
Tasha: 那就塞个你
Tasha: Then try to fit it.
Tasha: 你塞不进去换一个
Tasha: If it doesn't fit, try another one.
Tasha: 你也塞不进去
Tasha: You can't fit it either.
Katrina:  我们塞他
Katrina: Let's try him.
Alice: 这啥这是刺猬吗
Alice: What is this, a hedgehog?
Tasha: 可以他肯定就在这了
Tasha: It can be here for sure.
Lucia: 哦这是这是刺我以为他是太阳呢
Lucia: Oh, this is a hedgehog, I thought it was the sun.
小薇 : 土地公公的胯下
Tasha: Under the Earth God.
Lucia: 看哈哈哈像不像太阳
Lucia: Look, haha, doesn't it look like the sun?
Lucia: 我觉得这个太阳应该很好找到对应的
Lucia: I think this sun should be easy to match.
Lucia: 就因为他这里有很多的刺
Lucia: Because it has a lot of spikes.
Lucia: 所以我觉得这个是这里耶
Lucia: So I think this goes here.
Jake:这边这个像
Jake: This one looks like it.
Jake: 哇这个这个太严格了吧
Jake: Wow, this is too strict.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake: 我去这太严格了
Jake: Wow, this is too strict.
Jake: 如果都是这种严格程度的话
Jake: If everything is this strict,
Jake: 那确实对
Jake: then it really is.
Tasha: 那就好找了
Tasha: Then it will be easy to find.
Lucia: 胜利又顺利找到一个
Lucia: Victory, we found another one smoothly.
Alice: 谁没家
Alice: Who doesn't have a home?
Shure:  如今你四海为家
Shure: Now you feel at home everywhere.
Tasha: 怎么办还有这么多人没有家
Tasha: What to do, there are still so many people without a home?
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  回家回家
Shure: Going home, going home.
Shure:  回家是最好的礼物
Shure: Going home is the best gift.
Jake: 放BGM吧
Jake: Play the BGM.
Jake: 要不BGM再继续进去
Jake: Or continue the BGM.
Shure:  这时候应该放这个
Shure: This is the time to play this.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What to do?
Alice:标注一下为什么这时候要放这个BJM
Alice: Mark why we should play this BGM now.
Shure: BJM
Shure: BGM.
Lucia: 这是不是可以把这些
Lucia: Can we put these...
Tasha: 这个 好像真的是在这的
Tasha: This one really seems to be here.
Tasha: 嗯是吧
Tasha: Hmm, right?
Jake: 嗯很难很难说
Jake: Hmm, hard to say.
Jake: 有可能
Jake: Maybe.
Lucia: 能让AI把这些轮廓都扫描一下
Lucia: Can we get the AI to scan all these outlines?
Lucia: 然后让他帮忙拼吗
Lucia: And then have it help us piece them together?
Jake: 试试
Jake: Let's try.
Alice: 无限次试
Alice: Try as many times as we want.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 反正他算的快
Alice: Anyway, it's fast at calculating.
Lucia: 对就是应该有这种类似的软件吧
Lucia: Yeah, there should be some similar software, right?
Lucia: 不然就是那种乐高都是怎么设计的
Lucia: Otherwise, how do they design those Legos?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 动物世界
Alice: Animal world.
Alice: 哈哈哈这个应该是这样子的吧
Alice: Hahaha, it should be like this, right?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哎
Tasha: Hahaha, yeah.
Lucia: 很像很像
Lucia: Very similar.
Lucia: 应该是的
Lucia: It should be.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: So impressive.
Tasha: 他们俩捆绑了
Tasha: They're tied up.
Tasha: 对就是把
Tasha: Yeah, just put...
Lucia: 只要把那
Lucia: Just put those...
Lucia: 个能合上的都放在一起先
Lucia: pieces that can fit together first.
Lucia: 然后再看他们具体是个怎么回事把
Lucia: Then see how they actually fit.
Tasha: 把不对的拿出来
Tasha: Take out the ones that don't fit.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 昂这个这个肯定在边上
Lucia: Hmm, this one definitely goes on the edge.
Alice: 他俩是不是
Alice: Are they...
Lucia: 所以这个也可以这样放一下先放着这
Lucia: So we can place this here for now.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 但是这他这个这么明显
Lucia: But this one is so obvious.
Lucia: 应该会有一个
Lucia: There should be...
Alice: 他俩像不像一家的
Alice: Do they look like they're from the same family?
Alice: 感觉 是一家的
Alice: Feels like they are.
Tasha: 他们俩像一家的他
Tasha: They do look like family.
Alice:有没有那么严丝合缝的
Alice: Are they that perfectly matched?
Tasha: 他这样子吧
Tasha: Is it like this?
Tasha: 中间能不能再塞一条东西进来
Tasha: Can we fit something in between?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one...
Lucia: 是不是有点像啊
Lucia: Doesn't it look a bit like it?
Jake: 反过来不至于
Jake: It won't fit the other way around.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 或者在这里面谁是条条的
Alice: Or who here is Tiao Tiao's friend?
Tasha: 他他不一定对
Tasha: He, he might not be right
Tasha: 他拿走这这些小家伙都不对
Tasha: He's taking away these little guys, that's not right
Lucia: 这个有有谁是长成这样的
Lucia: Who here looks like this?
Tasha: 这样子
Tasha: Like this
Shure: 可以这个样子
Shure: Yeah, it can be like this
Shure:  在中间留着一点
Shure: Leave a bit in the middle
Shure:  然后这样
Shure: And then like this
Lucia: 昂有道理就可以
Lucia: Right, that makes sense
Lucia: 看这个和这两边感觉就比较
Lucia: Look, this and these two sides feel more...
Tasha: 哎我刚刚找的那个呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the one I just found?
Tasha: 哦不是
Tasha: Oh, never mind
Tasha: 我还找了一个呢
Tasha: I found another one
Alice: 我把它拆了
Alice: I took it apart
Alice: 拆成他俩了
Alice: Took it apart into two
Alice: 就你刚刚说的是这个吧
Alice: This is the one you were talking about, right?
Tasha: 昂
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 他又在上去存疑
Tasha: He's back up there being suspicious again
Lucia: 完了咱他俩这么长时间都没拼出来
Lucia: Oh no, we haven't figured this out after so long
Lucia: 要是放到下午大家拼可能也拼不出来
Lucia: If we leave it till the afternoon, everyone might still not figure it out
Katrina:  让他们玩一下午吧
Katrina: Let them play all afternoon
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Katrina:  这拼出来了给多少金币
Katrina: How many coins do we get if we figure it out?
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 先拼出来
Shure: First, figure it out
Tasha: 这个为什么在摸他的屁股
Tasha: Why is this one touching his butt?
Tasha: 然后这个蹲在他的屁股上
Tasha: And this one is squatting on his butt
Alice:你是来拉屎的吧
Alice: Are you here to poop?
Tasha: 哈哈哈真的是这样放的吗
Tasha: Hahaha, is it really supposed to be placed like this?
Lucia: 可也可能不是
Lucia: Maybe, maybe not
Shure:  这绝对不是
Shure: Definitely not
Shure:  太变态了
Shure: That's too weird
Tasha: 好了只有目前这些是确定的
Tasha: Okay, so only these are confirmed for now
Alice: 他的这个脚肯定
Alice: His foot definitely...
Lucia: 吗不太可能
Lucia: No way, that's not possible
Shure:  这个脚肯定插到谁的屁股里
Shure: This foot definitely goes into someone's butt
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 这个在这的
Tasha: This one goes here
Alice: 他揭着他的屁股好
Alice: He's lifting his butt, okay
Alice: 好尴尬
Alice: So awkward
Tasha: 刚刚谁说他是土地公公的
Tasha: Who just said he was the land god?
Alice: 哎这两个是不是可以在一块
Alice: Hey, can these two go together?
Tasha: 哦好了
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Alice: 再来一个
Alice: Let's do one more.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: Amazing.
Lucia: 感觉胜利在望了
Lucia: Feels like victory is in sight.
Tasha: 三人游戏
Tasha: Three-player game.
Shure:  三人游戏
Shure: Three-player game.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  这是个什么
Katrina: What's this?
Lucia: 这是个猴子吧
Lucia: Is this a monkey?
Jake: 哦是的
Jake: Oh, yes.
Alice: 哎这两个是不是可以在一块
Alice: Hey, can these two go together?
Tasha: 这样也挺搭的
Tasha: This looks good too.
Jake: 像吗哎
Jake: Really?
Tasha: 好像
Tasha: Seems like it.
Jake:一般像吧
Tasha: 两般吧
Tasha: Maybe twice?
Jake:有可能吧
Jake: Possibly.
Jake: 一般像
Jake: Usually like...
Tasha: 两个细长条形的
Tasha: Two long thin strips.
Jake: 这片头多久啊
Jake: How long is this intro?
Jake: 几分钟刚刚的
Jake: A few minutes just now.
Jake: 动物世界
Jake: Animal World.
Shure: 4分32秒
Shure: 4 minutes and 32 seconds.
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What?
Jake: 刚刚那个动物世界
Jake: The Animal World just now.
Jake: 4分32秒已经悄悄的过去了
Jake: 4 minutes and 32 seconds have quietly passed.
Tasha: 才过去4分钟吗
Tasha: Only 4 minutes?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 还好
Tasha: Not bad.
Jake: 还好
Jake: Not bad.
Lucia: 怎么觉得这个弧形边完全找不全
Lucia: Why does it feel like I can't find the whole curved edge?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 所以
Tasha: So...
Tasha: 这个算是这样子
Tasha: So this is like...
Alice:反了
Alice: It's reversed.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Alice: 反了吧没有反
Alice: Is it reversed? No, it's not.
Alice: 采供就四个了么
Alice: Only four suppliers now?
Tasha: 哎你刚不是把那个放在一起了吗
Tasha: Hey, didn't you just put that together?
Alice: 疑似
Alice: Maybe.
Lucia: 他到底是哪一边
Lucia: Which side is he really on?
Alice: 他是来迷惑你的
Alice: He's just trying to confuse you.
Lucia: 感觉两个好像都可以
Lucia: Feels like either side could work.
Alice: 不太不不太像这么大啊
Alice: Doesn't look that big, huh?
Shure:  血压高了怎么办
Shure: What if my blood pressure goes up?
Lucia: 哎会是这样的
Lucia: Hey, it could be like that.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 这个是在这个边边上吗
Tasha: Is this supposed to be on the edge?
Tasha: 这个是在边边上
Tasha: This is on the edge.
Lucia: don't you
Jake: 拆快递吧
Jake: Let's unbox the packages.
Jake: 要不哈哈
Jake: Or not, haha.
Jake: 拆会儿快递去拆快递拆快递拆会儿快递
Jake: Let's unbox some packages, unbox, unbox, unbox some packages.
Katrina:  我要去把我的花啊什么的
Katrina: I need to get my flowers and stuff.
Shure: 不行了 血压高了
Shure: No way, my blood pressure is high.
Shure:  血压高了
Shure: Blood pressure is high.
Tasha: 怎么怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Jake: 没有没有拆拆一会回来
Jake: No, no, unbox for a while and come back.
Jake: 呃呃就有灵感了你知道吧
Jake: Uh, then you'll get some inspiration, you know?
Tasha: 在哪拆快递
Tasha: Where to unbox?
Jake: 呃那边有一些快递
Jake: Uh, there are some packages over there.
Jake: 然后就过来拆
Jake: Then just come over and unbox.
Katrina:  我要整一波我的
Katrina: I need to sort my stuff.
Tasha: 我还有在菜鸟驿站的
Tasha: I still have some at the parcel station.
Jake: 嗯哦我看一下他们
Jake: Hmm, let me check them.
Tasha: 这俩脚
Tasha: These two feet.
Lucia: 哈哈好奇怪啊
Lucia: Haha, so weird.
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Lucia: How could that be?
Alice: 汉服不是在边边
Alice: The Hanfu isn't on the edge.
Lucia: 他在边也
Lucia: It's on the edge too.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  买几个
Katrina: Buy a few.
Tasha: 那把它按在这里面的哪里呢
Tasha: So, where do we place it inside here?
Lucia: 哈哈哈好问题
Lucia: Haha, good question.
Lucia: 啊是吗
Lucia: Ah, really?
Tasha: 是呀哎
Tasha: Yeah, hey.
Lucia: 反正我就是
Lucia: Anyway, I just...
Lucia: 我好不容易拼了其中的一部分
Lucia: I finally managed to piece together part of it.
Lucia: 然后就不会拼了
Lucia: Then I couldn't piece it together anymore.
Lucia: 然后我就放弃
Lucia: So I gave up.
Alice: 玩困了怎么办
Alice: What if we get tired of playing?
Shure:  喝杯咖啡吧
Shure: Have a cup of coffee.
Shure: 喝杯咖啡喝
Shure: Drink some coffee.
Alice:  感觉他俩是不是也可以这样
Alice: Do you think they could do it like this too?
Alice: 就一点点就成这样了
Alice: Just a little bit and it's done.
Katrina:  对但是我以为每
Katrina: Yeah, but I thought everyone
Katrina:  个人都要做
Katrina: had to do it.
Katrina:  一到两边边都不播放了
Katrina: One or two sides and it won't play anymore.
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Tasha: 大家挤一挤
Tasha: Everyone squeeze in.
Lucia: 哈哈电不够了
Lucia: Haha, the power is running out.
Alice:嗯勉强
Alice: Hmm, barely.
Tasha: 哎就这样
Tasha: Oh, just like that.
Lucia: 就是这样的哈哈
Lucia: That's how it is, haha.
Lucia: 非常对
Lucia: Exactly.
Tasha: 我感觉边是对了
Tasha: I think the edge is right.
Alice: 但我感觉这儿有点大
Alice: But I think this part is a bit big.
Tasha: 嗯但是感觉这边要重新组合组合
Tasha: Yeah, but I think this side needs to be reassembled.
Jake:我不知道为什么他
Jake: I don't know why it...
Tasha: 我觉得这边没问题
Tasha: I think this side is fine.
Tasha: 这边这边有问题
Tasha: This side has a problem.
Jake:断了他电有电是有电
Jake: It's disconnected, there's power though.
Tasha: 要把这几个重新组合一下
Tasha: We need to reassemble these few pieces.
Tasha: 但还是这几个边
Tasha: But still keep these edges.
Lucia: 总感觉这个牛
Lucia: I always feel this is amazing.
Lucia: 这里他应该能放一个什么东西进来
Lucia: Here, he should be able to put something in.
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But...
Lucia: 难道他也是一个
Lucia: Could it be that this is also a...
Lucia: 障眼法吗
Lucia: Deception?
Jake:有啊
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  这样就可以扩延充足
Katrina: This way it can be extended enough.
Lucia: 这个看起来其实也像在边上一样
Lucia: This actually looks like it's on the edge too.
Lucia: 看就是如果如果这样的话是吧
Lucia: See, if it's like this, right?
Lucia: 这个也是挺像在边上的
Lucia: This also looks like it's on the edge.
Katrina:  你这个花瓶呢
Katrina: What about this vase?
Katrina:  快递在哪看到的
Katrina: Where did you see it in the delivery?
Alice: 花瓶不是快递
Alice: The vase wasn't in the delivery.
Alice: 就在桌子上
Alice: It's on the table.
Alice: 有两个瓶子
Alice: There are two bottles.
Katrina:  哎我买了6个啊
Katrina: Hey, I bought six of them.
Jake:你买了
Jake: You bought them?
Tasha: 取得了历史性的进步啊
Tasha: We've made historic progress!
Jake:哪一个
Jake: Which one?
Lucia: 哈哈哈我们刚发现这是这样的
Lucia: Hahaha, we just found out it's like this.
Lucia: 然后这样又可以拼上哦
Lucia: And then you can piece it together like this.
Jake:哦妙啊
Jake: Oh, that's brilliant.
Tasha: 历史性的进步
Tasha: Historic progress.
Lucia: 不错不错
Lucia: Not bad, not bad.
Lucia: 胜利在望
Lucia: Victory is in sight.
Jake: 你买了几个花瓶
Jake: How many vases did you buy?
Katrina:  6个我当时想的是一人一个
Katrina: Six, I thought one for each person.
Jake: 嗯6个花瓶
Jake: Hmm, six vases.
Jake: 厨房看到了吗
Jake: Did you see the kitchen?
Jake: 看到了几个
Jake: How many did you see?
Katrina:  我看看都到了没
Katrina: Let me see if they all arrived.
Katrina:  好像都到了
Katrina: Seems like they're all here.
Tasha: 这个跟这个边上的
Tasha: This one and the one next to it.
Alice: 但是这感觉
Alice: But it feels like...
Lucia: 这个有可能在里面
Lucia: This one might be inside.
Lucia: 感觉它看起来好像都不太圆对吧
Lucia: Feels like it doesn't look very round, right?
Tasha: 嗯先把它放
Tasha: Hmm, let's place it first.
Tasha: 熊猫
Tasha: Panda.
Lucia: 哎这个也很像在边上有道理
Lucia: Hey, this one also seems like it makes sense on the side.
Katrina:  确实发了三个快递
Katrina: I did send three packages.
Katrina:  但是都到了
Katrina: But they're all here.
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay, good.
Tasha: 你们换个边
Tasha: You guys switch sides.
Alice: 更不像哎
Alice: It looks even less like it now.
Tasha: 这个感觉屏有点那种弧度是他吗
Tasha: This screen seems to have a bit of a curve, is it that one?
Alice: 不是不是这个也不是
Alice: No, no, it's not this one either.
Alice: 挑不下
Alice: Can't pick it out.
Lucia: 如果把那个鸟嘴冲着那边就是
Lucia: If you turn that bird's beak towards that side, then it's...
Lucia: 这样的话嗯好像也放不进去
Lucia: Like this, hmm, it doesn't seem to fit either.
Lucia: 这些东西有可能吗
Lucia: Could these things be possible?
Jake: 哎我拼几个这个吧
Jake: Hey, let me piece a few of these together.
Jake: 这个有用吗
Jake: Is this useful?
Jake: 这个这个要不
Jake: This, this one or...
Jake: 把白板给放下去
Jake: Put the whiteboard down.
Jake: 就是把白板给赶到这个上面
Jake: Just move the whiteboard onto this.
Shure:  要的怎么写太费劲了
Shure: Writing it down is too much trouble.
Katrina:  花都在这
Katrina: All the flowers are here.
Katrina:  哇你已经弄好了
Katrina: Wow, you already finished it.
Jake: 剪刀开
Jake: Open the scissors.
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Lucia: How could that be?
Shure: 剪刀
Shure: Scissors.
Katrina:  剪刀在外面
Katrina: The scissors are outside.
Katrina:  这加水了吗
Katrina: Did you add water to this?
Jake: 加过了应该对
Jake: Yes, it should be enough.
Katrina:  加过了是吧
Katrina: You added it, right?
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Jake:很专业
Jake: Very professional.
Alice: 好太难了太难了
Alice: Oh, it's so hard, so hard.
Tasha: 拼图天才
Tasha: Puzzle genius.
Lucia: 哈哈天才又找到一块
Lucia: Haha, the genius found another piece.
Tasha: 拼图天才
Tasha: Puzzle genius.
Tasha: 出世出山
Tasha: Coming out of retirement.
Jake: 真有意思
Jake: This is really interesting.
Lucia: 让我们看看有没有可能
Lucia: Let's see if it's possible.
Lucia: 在不依靠
Lucia: Without relying on it.
Lucia: 解析的情况下
Lucia: Without analysis.
Jake: 这尾巴试过
Jake: Have you tried this tail?
Alice: 有点大
Alice: It's a bit big.
Jake:没用确实
Jake: Indeed, it's useless.
Lucia: 这个呢有可能
Lucia: How about this one, maybe?
Lucia: 不太行
Lucia: Not really.
Lucia: 谁在中间呢
Lucia: Who's in the middle?
Tasha: 嗯刚刚这个好像不太行
Tasha: Hmm, this one doesn't seem right.
Alice: 他又跟谁分家了
Alice: Who did he split with again?
Tasha: 对他他在这
Tasha: Yes, he's here.
Tasha: 哎把小伙伴丢了
Tasha: Oh no, he lost his buddy.
Lucia: 哦这个这个这个在他的
Lucia: Oh, this, this, this is his.
Lucia: sorry忘记了
Lucia: Sorry, I forgot.
Lucia: 嗯对这是这样子的
Lucia: Hmm, yes, it's like this.
Lucia: 对对对这块就这样挺好
Lucia: Yes, yes, this piece fits nicely.
Tasha: 这样子挺好的
Tasha: This fits nicely.
Katrina:  所有快递都在外面了吗
Katrina: Are all the packages outside?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 今天还到了几个
Jake: Today, a few more arrived.
Jake: 但是还都会有管家过来送
Jake: But the housekeeper will still come to deliver them.
Shure:  还有管家
Shure: There's a housekeeper?
Tasha: 那他能把我的送来吗
Tasha: Can he deliver mine too?
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What thing?
Jake: 把什么东西培养皿
Jake: What thing? The petri dish?
Tasha: 我买的东西
Tasha: The stuff I bought.
Jake: 可以啊今天会有
Jake: Sure, it'll be here today.
Jake: 我问一下他们什么时候能
Jake: I'll ask them when they can...
Jake: 能来送
Jake: ...come to deliver.
Tasha: 好这游戏三个人玩刚刚好我们的
Tasha: Alright, this game is perfect for three people.
Alice: 掌管120组
Alice: Managing 120 groups.
Alice: 他俩会不会一家的
Alice: Could the two of them be from the same family?
Tasha: 他们仨是不是一个家的
Tasha: Are the three of them from the same family?
Lucia: 有可能但是总觉得哎
Lucia: Possibly, but I always feel like...
Lucia: 这里是不是应该稍微弧度再推一点
Lucia: Shouldn't we push this curve a bit more?
Tasha: 可是感觉不是那么严丝合缝
Tasha: But it doesn't seem to fit perfectly.
Tasha: 他们俩的宽度最匹配
Tasha: These two widths match the best.
Lucia: 然后放一下
Lucia: Then place it here.
Tasha: 是这个呢
Tasha: Is it this one?
Tasha: 这两个都有可能
Tasha: Both of these could work.
Katrina:  要帮忙不
Katrina: Need help?
Alice: 哎你觉得这个像不像在这
Alice: Hey, do you think this fits here?
Jake:额可以比划比划一块
Jake: Uh, you can compare them side by side.
Tasha: 这样子的
Tasha: Like this?
Lucia:哎是这两个应该是
Lucia: Hey, it's these two, right?
Katrina:  这是什么呀
Katrina: What is this?
Alice: 不过感觉这个搁哪儿都行啊只不过这个头对着他的屁股好像也挺严丝合缝的
Alice: But I feel like this can go anywhere, and this head fits snugly against its back.
Katrina:  我可以
Katrina: I can...
Katrina:  帮你们拧螺丝
Katrina: ...help you guys screw in the bolts.
Jake:好 比划比划
Jake: Alright, compare them.
Tasha: 这个这个是对的
Tasha: This one, this one is correct.
Jake: 喜欢拧螺丝
Jake: You like screwing bolts?
Jake: 就是刚刚拧的开心了
Jake: You just enjoyed screwing them earlier.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 要不装个机
Shure: How about assembling a machine?
Tasha: 咱俩配对啊
Tasha: Let's pair up.
Shure:  要不咱装个机
Shure: How about assembling a machine?
Jake: 好给你买一个台电脑
Jake: Alright, I'll get you a computer.
Jake: 从头装哇
Jake: We'll assemble it from scratch.
Jake: 怎么出来的
Jake: How did it come out?
Tasha: 这个是吗
Tasha: Is this it?
Alice: 有长有长这样的吗没有吧
Alice: Does this look like it? No, right?
Jake:白板墙
Jake: Whiteboard wall.
Tasha: 嗯因为好
Tasha: Hmm, because it's good.
Lucia: 长这样的
Lucia: Looks like this.
Jake:快弄出来了，回不去
Jake: Hurry up, we can't go back.
Tasha: 这不像应该不是
Tasha: This doesn't seem right, probably not.
Tasha: 这个暂且配对吧
Tasha: Let's pair this for now.
Jake: 这啥意思
Jake: What does this mean?
Jake: 试试比划比划
Jake: Try it, compare it.
Tasha: 这个跟谁都能配这个
Tasha: This can pair with anything.
Tasha: 我就说我是个拼图天才
Tasha: I said I'm a puzzle genius.
Alice: 我这个在亮吗
Alice: Is this one on?
Alice: 为什么感觉这是红色的
Alice: Why does it look red?
Jake: 在亮在亮
Jake: It's on, it's on.
Shure:  没问题看一下安装图纸
Shure: No problem, check the installation manual.
Jake: 看一下那个红色是红色你这电量太少了
Jake: Look at it, that red is red. Your battery is too low.
Jake: 我看一下你的这个电在哪冲
Jake: Let me see where you charge this.
Shure:  这个是我我看一下这个对
Shure: This is mine, let me check, right.
Jake:我能看一下这个
Jake: Can I check this?
Shure:  放下面的
Shure: Put it underneath.
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Katrina:  跟他对接
Katrina: Connect it with this.
Shure:  这有两个螺丝
Shure: There are two screws here.
Alice: 这在录吗
Alice: Is this recording?
Jake: 这个在录
Jake: This is recording.
Jake: 然后这个正在充
Jake: And this is charging.
Jake: 所以没关系
Jake: So it's okay.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 这就是电太少了
Jake: It's just low on battery.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 这是干嘛的嗯
Jake: What is this for, hmm?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  叠开关
Katrina: Stack the switches.
Katrina:  游戏
Katrina: Game.
Katrina:  高度调节
Katrina: Adjust the height.
Jake: 安装图这个样子
Jake: The installation manual looks like this.
Jake: 这样是吧
Jake: Like this, right?
Shure: 这两个是这儿嗯
Shure: These two go here, hmm.
Jake: 这是这
Jake: This is this
Jake: 下面这是什么
Jake: What's this below
Jake: 下面还有一条
Jake: There's another one below
Katrina:  你把它反过来是不是这
Katrina: If you flip it over, is it this
Shure:  oh
Shure: oh
Jake: oh
Shure:  holy shit what
Shure: holy shit what
Jake: what what
Shure:  耶
Shure: Yeah
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: hahaha
Katrina:  要这样弄紧靠紧
Katrina: You need to tighten it up like this
Jake: 哪个距离不对吗
Jake: Is the distance not right
Katrina:  确实该弄长一点
Katrina: It should be a bit longer
Tasha: 是吗中间这个中间中间这个是谁
Tasha: Really? Who is this in the middle, the middle one?
Jake:哎不这个有点 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh no, this is a bit... Oh my gosh
Jake: 这边这边有点别扭的这边就是这个大概是这个哎
Jake: This side is a bit awkward, this side is like this, roughly like this
Jake: 他是有斜度吗
Jake: Is it slanted
Jake: 还是他是直的呀
Jake: Or is it straight
Jake: 平行的看起来
Jake: It looks parallel
Tasha: 他俩好像是一起的
Tasha: They seem to be together
Jake:他两是平行的
Jake: They are parallel
Tasha: 可能原本不是挨着这个屁股对
Katrina:  他这个长度是固定的是吗
Katrina: Is the length fixed
Jake:他这个 他哎呦
Jake: This one, this one, oh
Shure: 放倒
Shure: Lay it down
Jake: 他这个他这个得弄长一点吗可以吧对
Jake: This one, this one needs to be longer, right
Katrina:  昂他是可以调节长度的
Katrina: Yeah, it can be adjusted
Jake: 哎不对不对不对不是这个得是平行的这两平行的
Jake: No, no, no, these two need to be parallel
Tasha: 可能他不在这儿就是这只是大概的
Tasha: Maybe it's not here, this is just roughly
Alice: 感觉
Alice: It feels like
Jake: 然后这个
Jake: And then this
Lucia: 如果真的在一块的话
Lucia: If they are really together
Jake:这个太长了可能
Jake: This might be too long
Lucia: 可能就变成这样了
Lucia: It might become like this
Lucia: 但是我找不到了
Lucia: But I can't find it
Tasha: 从中间这个如果没有的话就不是
Tasha: If this one in the middle is missing, then it's not
Jake:来一会咱用尺
Jake: Let's use a ruler in a bit
Jake:来这样这样行吗
Jake: Like this, is this okay
Shure: 整个大概就行
Shure: Just roughly
Tasha: 也不知道谁和谁对
Tasha: No idea who goes with who
Jake:打开打开嗯
Jake: Open it, open it, yeah.
Tasha: 是他们俩对还是他们俩
Tasha: Is it those two or those two?
Shure: 啊 不这样 我们先把一一边固定上就好了
Shure: Ah, no, let's first secure one side.
Shure:  让他不乱窜
Shure: So it doesn't move around.
Jake: 固定一个吧
Jake: Let's secure one side.
Jake: 行或者应该倒倒下来得了倒下来
Jake: Or we could flip it over, flip it over.
Lucia: 有点难搞
Lucia: It's a bit tricky.
Lucia: 感觉拼困了累了歇一歇
Lucia: I feel like I'm tired from assembling, need a break.
Lucia: 他们那边拼那个需要帮忙呢
Lucia: Do they need help with their assembly over there?
Shure:  那个拿拿耳朵呢
Shure: They're working on the ears.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Jake: 你们拼完了
Jake: Are you guys done assembling?
Lucia: 没有对
Lucia: No, not yet.
Jake: 先休息一会是吧
Jake: Let's take a break first.
Shure:  对拼困了
Shure: Yeah, tired from assembling.
Jake:对行
Jake: Yeah, okay.
Lucia: 决定看看有没有什么其他可以帮忙的
Lucia: I'll see if there's anything else I can help with.
Jake: 我们房间要不要
Jake: How about our room?
Jake: 我可能要装饰一下
Jake: I might need to decorate a bit.
Jake: 要不我们踩个风
Jake: Or we could check things out.
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That's fine too.
Lucia: 我们是只只把一楼这个客厅装饰一下
Lucia: Are we just decorating the living room on the first floor?